en géographie nous reste-t-il des choses
à découvrir
ça c'est la grosse question si on
considère que les jo la géographie se
limite à la représentation de la terre
comme l'a dit paul valéry aujourd'hui on
est en présence d'un monde fini même
s'ils restent au fin fond de l'amazonie
en papouasie nouvelle guinée ou autres
des taches blanches dans lequel l'homme
n'a pas encore pénétrer mais si on prend
la géographie comme une représentation
de l'univers
on peut considérer que la terre n'est
qu'une infime partie est aujourd'hui et
il reste tout à découvrir
et il faut également s'intéresser à mars
vénus jupiter et la géographie elle doit
être planétaire et doit englober le
cosmos on peut considérer qu'on en est à
ce moment là ses balbutiements
[Musique]